hey kim hi david so with the republican
national convention coming up in just a
couple of weeks as we're recording this
you thought it would be like a really
good idea to sit down and examine the
history of the republican party so
what's what's going on in the country in
1854 that leads to
this party forming well there are
growing discussions over slavery and
whether slavery should expand to the
west now all throughout the 19th century
the citizens of the united states had
been kind of compromising on the issue
of slavery first they had a line between
north and south said only slave states
could be below this line now the kansas
nebraska act overturns that compromise
the kansas-nebraska act which says that
the citizens of a territory when
applying for statehood can themselves
decide whether or not that state should
have slavery so even though kansas and
nebraska are north of this parallel in
missouri
above which slavery couldn't exist
this new law kind of overturns that that
agreement exactly so a number of u.s
citizens who are anti-slavery
which means that they don't want slavery
to spread
into western territories mainly because
they want those territories free for
white farmers to not have to compete
with wealthy slaveholders who have free
labor to farm and ship their goods and
sell their crops what about people that
hate slavery and think it's immoral and
want to abolish it those people are
called abolitionists that's a convenient
name yes and the abolitionists really
before the 1850s they were kind of
considered the lunatic fringe only
those sorts of people would imagine that
you would want to end slavery right now
everywhere that exists in the united
states so they don't want to just not
have slavery out in the west they want
slavery to be ended where it exists
already in the south right so those who
believed in abolition those who believed
in anti-slavery went to a new party the
republican party so even
in within the republican party
abolitionism was still on the the fringe
of the party plank yeah i would say so
so
the new republican party which really
comes out to an extremely strong start
they run their first candidate in 1856
he gets second place in national
election which is amazing
but their second candidate for president
is abraham lincoln
and lincoln himself is actually kind of
considered a moderate
because
he is anti-slavery he's not an
abolitionist
but nonetheless the south perceives
lincoln to be an abolitionist and white
southerners revolt and start the civil
war so because he's perceived as an
abolitionist because he is a republican
that's why south carolina secedes
exactly so the civil war ensues this is
a four year long battle 620 000
americans die and at the end of the day
the
north the united states of america led
by the republican party is victorious so
the victory of the united states in this
civil war kind of assures dominion of
the republican party for a generation
right yeah i would say even more than
that so for the rest of the 19th century
and really or into the early 20th
century the republican party is the
stronger political party in the united
states
so from the end of the end of the civil
war from 1865 until about when would you
say i would say the great depression so
it's it's an almost unbroken string of
republican presidencies yeah there are
only three democratic presidents in this
time period so it's 72 years of pretty
much uninterrupted republican rule and
the republican party is the party of
anti-slavery during the civil war
they're the party of the emancipation
proclamation under lincoln so it's
during their rule that the 13th
amendment abolishing slavery is passed
the 14th amendment which guarantees
equal citizenship to african americans
is passed and the 15th amendment
guaranteeing the right to vote for
african americans is passed so in the
period immediately following the civil
war called reconstructions when we see
the election of some of the first
african-american senators and
representatives to the congress exactly
so during this time period quite a few
african-american men were elected to us
congress and many more served in
appointed roles like postmaster
so this is when we get the election of
senator hiram revels from mississippi
exactly
so hiram revels was one of the first two
african-american
senators so after the civil war the
republican party was really kind of this
party of the gilded age they believed in
modernizing the infrastructure of the
united states they built lots of
railroads they enacted policies that
would protect american business and it's
really in this early period of the turn
of the century that the republican party
becomes associated with protections of
business there does that is that what
the elephant's about uh kind of yes so
the elephant was
popularized in an 1870 cartoon by thomas
nast well the same guy that gave us
santa claus right yes um and
nast depicted the republican party as an
elephant because it was a party of
strength right a really big
consequential party that's so
fascinating to have gone from this like
insurgency party to this like to being
perceived as the elephant of electoral
politics in 30 years yeah it's amazing
unfortunately it kind of all comes
crashing down with the great depression
sure so the pro-business policies the
lack of regulation in the 1920s leads to
the stock market crash of 1929 and it
was a republican president herbert
hoover who was in the presidency at the
time of the crash and so in 1932
democrat franklin roosevelt is elected
president and the following 40 years
more or less are going to be
the time of democratic ascendancy
but in the meantime there is one notable
republican president um
i like
you like
everybody likes
so we're quoting one of uh ike's
campaign commercials who was ike kim and
ike was general dwight eisenhower who
was a world war ii hero um he was so
popular he would have been elected had
his could have been from the martian
party right
yes
like any party except the communist
party would have propelled eisenhower to
the presidency yes exactly and you're
right that one of the you know key
themes of this time period was
anti-communism and both republicans and
democrats had an anti-communist bent but
eisenhower was elected in 1952 and he
was really the first president to use
commercial spots to get elected he had
these cute little jingles that were very
memorable
and he really used the medium of
television well so he's kind of the the
father of tv ads yeah it's interesting
because i think we think of kennedy as
being the first television president but
i would i think we could both make the
claim that it's it's really eisenhower
that is a great point so eisenhower is
kind of a republican moment in a much
larger democratic era and this is the
era when the civil rights movement
happens this is the era of the great
society programs which were lyndon
johnson's programs to try to attack
poverty and new deal programs so this is
really the birth of the welfare state
so in this time period the republicans
begin to experience a demographic shift
so first they had been the party that
was most known for representing african
americans because they were the party of
lincoln but during the new deal
when most people really needed economic
help the african-american constituency
moved over to the democrats they
actually had a campaign saying to
african americans turn your picture of
abraham lincoln to the wall
so that he can't see you change parties
but this is really the time period when
the democratic party begins to pick up
the votes of african americans and so
over the course of the 1930s through the
1960s as the democratic party begins to
advocate bigger and bigger government a
larger welfare state and more and more
social progress the republicans develop
a conservative
response to that and in the 1970s and
1980s in the aftermath of the civil
rights movement many whites in the south
felt that the social chaos of the civil
rights movement had gone too far and so
they left the democratic party which had
been traditionally a party in the south
and joined the republican party which
was presenting a more conservative
face towards social change and so in the
1980s
this new conservative movement really
came together in the person of ronald
reagan
and ronald reagan brought together a
number of constituencies he brought
together business
interests
who wanted less government regulation of
business he also brought together uh
christian evangelicals
who
wanted a more conservative social value
program in government
and he also brought together
anti-communists who felt that the
democratic presidents had been too soft
on communism during their tenure so this
is interesting to me because it seems to
be around the era of reagan that we
start to see the beginnings of
ideological polarization within the
parties
i would say that's kind of
been
around since the beginning uh more or
less you know the
two original political parties in the
united states the federalists and the
anti-federalists or the democratic
republicans this is the party led by
thomas jefferson versus the party led by
alexander hamilton you know they had
this same idea of
the sort of large central government
versus the small central government in
many ways we're still debating the same
issues that hamilton and jefferson were
debating in 1800 so okay so we're seeing
this conservative coalition
coalesce around the election of reagan
and his election was like a sweep right
yes yeah uh he deregulates a lot of
industries um
he defends
conservative social family values like
prayer in school for example and he
takes a very hard line against communism
and george w bush who was the most
recent republican president had a fairly
similar agenda although less emphasis on
anti-communism and instead an emphasis
on anti-terrorism so we're seeing this
shift over the last 150 years of party
priorities for the republicans as the
country changes and as its demographics
change and we'll find out how the story
of the republican party continues in
this election